[Musique]
je crois que il faut qu'on remette à
plat un certain nombre d'idées
la façon d exprimer j'ai eu l'occasion
de dire à d'autres médias dans cette
campagne et pardonnez moi j'espère que
les enfants ne nous regarde pas je vais
utiliser un gros mot je nous ai trouvés
chiant
pas d'idées nouvelles pas d'aspérités
enfin que
ça manquait de vie ça et je crois que
pour mener une campagne présidentielle
il faut à la fois parler bien sûr le
langage de la raison et par les
programmes il faut aussi parler le
langage du coeur il faut se lâcher il
faut il faut faire rêver les français
[Musique]
je pense qu'il faut qu'on soit une
droite explicative et droite assumé nous
commettons une erreur de diagnostic
j'entends partout les idées de droite
sont majoritaires totalement fou les
idées droite ne sont pas que tour de
l'autorité du besoin d'autorité l'idée
centrale de la bande c'est la liberté il
faut expliquer aux français que c'est à
nous que monsieur macron prétend nous
donner de la liberté mais qui nous en
donne pas et que nous notre objectif
c'est la liberté d'entreprendre la
liberté d'assumer sa vie individuelle la
liberté individuelle c'est cette liberté
là qui nous protègera or n'est plus
protégé par la liberté que par l'égalité
car je comprends bien dans ce monde
troublé que les français ce besoin de
protection bien il vaut mieux plus de
liberté que plus d'égalité pour répondre
à ce besoin de protection et sa cette
philosophie là je pense qu'elle nous a
manqué
je trouve que dans les grandes
difficultés que connaît la france ça ce
n'est pas absurde de travailler avec le
président réélu la ligne qui a été
choisie est donc celle d'une opposition
mais ce sera en tout cas pour ce qu'on
veut dans les yvelines une opposition
constructive
[Musique]